ah
it's my privilege to welcome dr. Daniel
B Copeland who's an associate professor
of education at Hillsdale College he
received his PhD in education from
Michigan State University and at
Hillsdale he serves as an advisor for
the classical education minor and the
liberal arts teacher apprenticeship in
addition to serving as a consultant for
the college's charter school initiative
he also serves on the board of directors
of the Society for classical learning
and on the editorial board for arts of
Liberty but journal on liberal arts and
liberal education in 2013 dr. Copeland
was voted professor of the Year by
Hillsdale senior class please welcome me
in joining dr. Daniel Copeland
well thank you for the great
introduction I'm really pleased to be
here and I'm gonna spend a little bit of
time talking about common core and I'd
be happy to answer your questions at the
end on May 29th 2009 Arne Duncan the new
Secretary of Education for the old of
the Obama administration gave a speech
at the National Press Club here in
Washington DC in the speech he said
quote we want to raise the bar
dramatically in terms of high standards
what we have as a country I'm convinced
is what we call a race to the bottom we
have 50 different standards 50 different
goal posts and dual and due to political
pressure those have all been dumbed down
we want to fundamentally reverse that we
want common career-ready internationally
benchmarked standards in this short
paragraph the Secretary of Education
identified the problems of the past and
set a new vision for education in this
country he correctly assessed the the
damage created in the Bush
administration's education policy from
2002 known as No Child Left Behind or
NCLB while supporters of NCLB can point
to limited success in a few areas of the
Bush administration's education policy
left the nation schools a bureaucratic
mess in the National Press Club speech
the new Secretary of Education was
arguing that the mess was created by
what he and others have called a
patchwork of state standards that left
the states to compete in a fundamentally
flawed and unfair process for limited
federal funds secretary Duncan's
argument presented at the National Press
Club and elsewhere was very persuasive
to those in the education community who
had suffered under the separate but very
unequal policy
of the era known as No Child Left Behind
four years later after the 2009 speech
all but a handful of states have signed
on to a common set of curriculum
standards known as Common Core Common
Core will now provide the framework for
what students will learn in math and
English language arts but it'll also
establish two federally funded and
approved tests that will replace what
states currently use to measure their
students academic success afraid to be
left out of the new education
marketplace private companies are
quickly trying to align themselves with
Common Core Standards in order to
survive in the Common Core era the
textbook publishers and other related
industries must show how their materials
align with common core SAT and a CT
tests are now lined with Common Core as
well and those who think they can avoid
Common Core but by having their
children's attend private schools or by
homeschooling should think again the
Iowa test of the basic skills and stand
for 10 - very popular tests with private
schools and with home schoolers will
also be aligned to common core within a
few short years Common Core has gone
from virtual unknown to national
education powerhouse that may influence
the formal education of some 50 million
k-12 students in America in the next few
minutes I'll try to give you some
insight on what Common Core is what the
major arguments are both for and against
and I'll also try to show how these
arguments are missing the most important
ideas about education altogether but
first I'll start with a brief history
the idea of a rich educational
experience has its roots deep in
American history of the founders of this
country believes and informs
citizenry was necessary for good
government in the 1800s
Horace Mann continued this legacy by
arguing for widespread public education
in the late 18-hundreds policy
politicians and social leaders look to
the schools to solve pressing social
needs brought on by industrialization
urbanization and immigration many many
leading educators that leading education
theorists of the late 19th and early
20th century including John Dewey
William H Kilpatrick G Stanley Hall and
others developed and promoted
progressive solutions to these pressing
social needs for the first half of the
20th century progressive theories such
as child centered teaching and practical
work-related curricula pretty much
dominated the education landscape in
October 1957 I'm sorry the United States
was awakened from its educational
malaise when the Soviet Union
successively launched Sputnik the first
space satellite into orbit this one
event signaled America's educational
decline and brought attention to the
need for a return to rich content at
least in the fields of math science and
foreign languages but these reforms were
quickly lost in the cultural turmoil of
1960s and 70s and schools once again
offered a smorgasbord of academically
weak classes students were earning
academic credit in courses titled
personal relationships what's happening
and Girl Talk and they were receiving
academic credit for extracurricular
activities in student government mass
media and cheerleading
in 1983 the National Commission on
excellence in education published a
landmark study on American education
titled a nation at risk which warned
that our country's economic cultural and
political future was threatened by our
weak education system the report stated
the now-famous lines
quote our nation is at risk the
educational foundations of society are
presently being eroded by the rising
tide of mediocrity that threatens our
very future as a nation and a people if
an unfriendly power had attempted to
impose on America the mediocre education
performance that exists today we might
well have viewed it as an act of war end
quote
a nation at risk signaled a turning
point in American education and brought
about renewed concentration on what
America's children should know and be
able to do Eadie Hirsch's 1987 book
cultural literacy argued that schools
should concentrate on the basics and
pass along core knowledge that every
educated American should know but many
in the education establishment resisted
these content-based reforms and continue
to push a progressive agenda in
America's schools with the collapse of
the Soviet Union in the 1980s in the end
of the Cold War many countries had
greater opportunities to participate in
the global marketplace globalization led
to international comparisons across a
variety of indicators including in
education many Asian countries with whom
we were now competing seemed to be
moving further and further ahead of the
United States one of the obvious
features of the education in these
countries was the existence of clear
national standards many reformers pushed
the idea in the United States or that if
the United States was
going to compete in the international
marketplace the quality of education in
the entire country would have to improve
they also concluded that such
improvement would only occur if students
were held to high academic standards in
1989 President George W I'm sorry
President George Bush the senior hosted
an educational conference in the nation
I'm sorry
conference for the nation's governors on
academic standards and testing Acuras
Matic Governor from Arkansas named
William Jefferson Clinton took the lead
in crafting a set of goals for
increasing academic achievement in
America and when Clinton defeated Bush
for the presidency three years later the
new President used these goals to craft
his signature education policy known as
goals 2000 goals 2000 provided money for
each state to develop its own standards
that were based on a national template
critics of the initiative claimed that
this effort violated the long-standing
principle established by the Tenth
Amendment of the US Constitution that
education was the responsibility of the
states but the Clinton administration
countered that the national standards
were met only to be a template for the
standards are sorry for the states to
follow and each state was ultimately
responsible for its own standards
interestingly goals 2000 also authorized
the creation of an approval board that
would certify state standards that
they'd had actually matched the National
template the approval board however
never materialized because in the 1994
midterm election the Republicans gained
the majority in Congress and they
quickly
I'm abolished the entire
bored even without the federal board the
effort to create state standards that
were based on a national template
continued in the mid 1990s professional
subject specific organizations release
national standards in history English
and math the general public assumed that
these standards would represent the
basic knowledge and skills that students
would need in these specific areas but
they soon discovered that these
professional organizations had used this
project to push unproven and perhaps
radical ideas within the academic fields
public opposition to these national
standards spread quickly
most states avoided the controversy of
the national standards by creating their
own unique standards if there was one
thing in common across these state
standards it was there are their
emphasis on less controversial skills
such as critical thinking cooperative
learning and shared understanding rather
than concrete statements about specific
ideas people and the books that students
should read in 2001 President George
Bush jr. pushed his education policy
known as No Child Left Behind or NCLB
which like those before it promised to
increase student achievement by
encouraging States to set high standards
and develop tests that were based on
those standards but unlike the in but
unlike the initiatives that had come
before it
NCLB required States to test all
students in particular subjects at
particular grade levels in order to
receive money looking back most
education experts both on the right and
the left concluded that NCLB had failed
to deliver real and lasting success
NCLB created an environment where
teaching to the test became the status
quo and what made matters worse was that
from state to stay
the tests were all different under NCLB
each statement had it each state had its
own academic standards that it was
expected to meet and because other money
was up based on each state meeting its
own standards
there was little motivation for states
to keep the academic standards high in
an effort to show higher proficiency and
student achievement students but I'm
sorry states begin lowering proficiency
levels in what the Secretary of
Education referred to as a race to the
bottom and by the end of the decade many
in the education community were looking
for alternatives to the separate and
unequal approach to standards from NCLB
in 2007 to trade organizations than
National Governors Association in the
Council of Chief state school officers
began work on a common set of curricular
standards in English language arts and
math in December of 2008 these two
groups produced I'm a document on
national standards that would guide the
new administration during its transition
into office two months later how the
Secretary of Education announced a new
grant program known as race to the top
the name was an obvious nod to the
failures of No Child Left Behind the
program included money from the 2009
stimulus bill which was used by the
states to improve academic standards and
tests in order to receive the race to
the top grant states had to commit to
quote a set of content standards that
define what students must know and be
able to do that are substantially
identical across all states in a
consortium end quote in 2011
I the obama administration made the
decision to adopt common standards even
easier
most states were still obligated to meet
the onerous NCLB requirements the US
Department of Education promised NCLB
waivers to states that adopted common
set of college and career-ready
standards and assessments and while the
US Department of Education did not
require States to adopt the common core
standards these standards were and still
are the only standards that met the
Education Department's criteria 45
states and the District of Columbia I'm
adopted the common core standards
Minnesota adopted the English language
arts standards but it rejected the math
standards initially only Alaska and
Texas rejected common core but in the
end of Virginia and Nebraska did to the
idea of common academic standards across
all states is quite appealing to many in
the field of education because it seems
secure some obvious and long-standing
problems allow me to highlight two of
the most important first and our mobile
society it makes it very easy for people
to pick up and move as Eadie Hirsch
points out quote in a typical American
School District the average rate at
which students transfer in and out of
schools during an academic year is about
one third in a typical urban school only
about half of the students who start in
September are still there in May when
students move from school to school
especially when these moves are across
state lines they often experience a
fractured education filled with huge
gaps and boring or boring repetitions
however if all schools are meeting the
same academic standards the students
have a greater chance at a relatively
assist in education regardless of where
they move within the country in theory
students should be able to move from
Maine to California with very little
interruption in their education number
two for years the United States has
lagged behind many of the industrialized
countries in key academic areas such as
math and science since Sputnik
policymakers have tried to craft a
coherent plan to improve our country
standing in the world but they have
struggled to do this in light of the
patchwork of state standards pointing to
the failures of NCLB proponents of
Common Core argue that having a common
set of academically rigorous standards
for the entire country would allow other
policymakers to craft a coherent plan
for improving American education many
corporate leaders and policymakers argue
that if we are if we are unable to
compete as an as a nation in a global
sea I'm sorry many corporate leaders and
politicians argue that we are unable to
compete as a nation in a global society
if every state is doing its own thing
the arguments against common core as you
can probably guess Common Core has its
critics who typically concentrate on one
or more of the following concerns number
one cost critics claim that Common Core
will be very expensive to implement and
maintain the only study on the cost of
implementing Common Core and its tests
on across other nation estimate the
price tag of sixteen billion dollars
over seven years but the truth of the
matter is that no one really knows what
the final price tag will be for this
reason and others critics have already
labeled this program Obama core critics
of Common
charge that most states acted
irresponsibly when they when they chose
to adopt other standards because they
did not have a firm understanding of the
price tag
many states saw the race to the top
month
I'm sorry money as a way to pay for
immediate education expenses but they
failed to see that they were signing on
for something far worse
number two quality critics argue that
rather than pushing states towards high
standards Common Core is encouraging a
coalescence at the mediocre middle
for example while Mississippi standards
appear to be getting stronger
Massachusetts by the standards in
Massachusetts get weaker a few curricula
experts including Zev Worman Sandra's
statsky James Milgram had examined the
math and English language arts standards
very carefully and they discovered some
alarming concerns in fact because of
these concerns and others Starsky and
Milgram who served on the common core's
validation committee refused to sign the
validation report number three privacy
the 2009 stimulus bill required States
to begin tracking students in a database
starting with their preschool years -
the entry into the workforce the
database will link students results on
common core related tests to other
private personal information the
database will be available to a wide
variety of people within the government
while supporters of common core claim
that the system employs a variety of
measures to protect the anonymity of
students critics have pointed to studies
that demonstrate how these measures may
not be as secure as supporters assume
however the larger issue remains about
whether collect
this kind of information is consistent
with the role of government that we have
in this country
number four constitutionality of the
biggest concern of common core critics
to date has been the ever creasing in
role of the national government in
education the Tenth Amendment of the US
Constitution established the the
principle that the power to oversee
education belongs to the states this
long-standing principle of local control
of Education is reiterated throughout
our laws and our government codes for
generations Americans have understood
that the constitutional authority for
education rests with the states or local
government not the federal government
critics of common core see that these
standards are federal overreach and a
violation of both the letter and the
spirit of federal education law and the
US Constitution supporters of common
core like to portray these critics as
far-right extremists who are paranoid
about the government about a government
takeover but this is not true Diane
Ravich a respected historian of
education is hardly the darling of the
right especially recently on a February
26 of this year Ravitz wrote the
following piece titled why I suppose or
why I oppose Common Core standards for
comments below give a general overview
of many of the central concerns that
most critics have I mean a quota at
length quote I've been a long advocate
or I have long advocated for voluntary
national standards believing that it
would be helpful to States and to school
districts to have general guidelines
about what students should know
and be able to do as they progress
through school such standards I believe
should be volunteering not imposed by
the federal government for the past two
years I have steadfastly insisted that I
was neither for nor against Common Core
I was agnostic I wanted to see how they
worked in practice after much
deliberation I have come to the
conclusion that Common Core standards
effort is fundamentally flawed by the
process with which they have been
foisted upon the nation end quote
ravage goes on to explain her opposition
to common core quote the creation was
neither grassroots nor did it emanate
from the states in fact it was well
understood by the states that they would
not be eligible for a Race to the Top
funding unless they adopted Common Core
Standards federal law prohibits the US
Department of Education from prescribing
any curriculum but in this case the
Department figured out a clever way to
evade the letter of the law 46 states in
the District of Columbia signed on not
because Common Core Standards were
better than their own but because they
wanted their share of federal cash end
quote
the response from common core supporters
regarding the federal overreach has been
surprisingly weak michelle rhee are the
former Chancellor of the DC Public
Schools and a well known education a
reformer which I often times kind of
find myself agreeing with her is a
strong supporter of Common Core in a
speech just last week on Mackinac Island
in my home
State to political leaders and to
businesspeople
she said this quote the last majority of
states have adopted the standards I've
heard some rumblings from people who say
we don't like when the federal
government is telling us what to do we
don't like that you know what you should
not like the fact that China is kicking
our rear ends right now get over feeling
bad about the federal government and
feel bad that our kids are not competing
end quote
I certainly hope that our country's
commitment to the Constitution does not
simply hang on something as fragile as a
feeling that we are able to get over
Riis cavalier critique of those who are
concerned about federal overreach is
troubling but I for one appreciate her
honesty most supporters of common core
tried to hide behind words like
state-led and voluntary but anyone
willing to take an honest look at what
transcribed or what transpired between
2009 and 2011 would conclude that many
of these cash-strapped states already
under the burden of a budget shortfall
an expensive NCLB requirements were
seduced by a high pressured
time-sensitive sales pitch for I'm
adopting other standards that included
relief in the form of money and waivers
yes the states are ultimately
responsible for selling their
constitutional birthright for I'm a bowl
of porridge and given more time perhaps
many more states might have rejected a
poor bargain like this but perhaps it's
not too late initially Common Core
experienced widespread support even some
prominent Republicans were strong
supporters of it
like Jeb Bush of Florida chris Christie
of New Jersey and mitch daniels of
indiana but support for common core
seems to be weakening in some states
that originally had adopted other
standards are starting to take a second
look this spring the Michigan House of
Representatives voted essentially to
defund the implementation of common core
in Indiana the state Senate voted to
delay implementation of common core so
that the State Board of Education could
take a closer look at the quality cost
and the loss of local control connected
with the implementation of common core
in Indiana in April Indiana's new
governor Mike Pence agreed to take quote
a long hard look
end quote at common core and quickly
added that he was one of the few
politicians - initially opposed no the
no child left behind other states are
considering legislative action to delay
or defund Common Core within the last
nine months the following states have
held public forums or formal legislative
hearings to discuss delaying or
defunding common core South Carolina
North Carolina Georgia Florida Alabama
Louisiana Missouri Kansas Colorado Utah
Idaho South Dakota Ohio Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin in April the National
Republican Committee passed an anti
Common Core resolution saying that the
RNC quote rejects the common core plan
which creates and fits the country with
a straitjacket on academic freedom and
achievement end quote
never to be outdone the state of Texas
reiterated its opposition to Common Core
in early May the Texas House of
Representatives formally rejected the
standards by a margin of a hundred and
forty to two last month a poll of
Education insiders which include an ash
and state education leaders discovered
that support for common core is
beginning to fade the polls showed that
63% of those polled believe that the
states will implement some form of
moratorium on common core and it would
be wrong to assume that the opposition
to common core is coming only from the
right recently Randi Weingarten the
president of the second largest teachers
union in the United States with a
million members almost a million members
called for a moratorium on the use of
standardized tests that are connected
with Common Core miss wine Gardner
initially a strong supporter of Common
Core is concerned that aspects of Common
Core have been poorly implemented and
that without a quote mid-course
correction the entire effort will fall
apart the idea of a common nationwide
standard I'm sorry the idea of common
nationwide standards is appealing and as
I mentioned above the benefits of such
standard should not be ignored but
concerns over common core and especially
its implementation are real and
troubling any of these concerns cost
mediocrity federal overreach are serious
enough that states should consider
pausing and perhaps ultimately repealing
their adoption of the standards but a
much more fundamental concern exists
about common core that goes to the heart
of any educational experience recall the
comment from Arne Duncan from the
beginning of my talk he said we want
common career-ready standards the phrase
career ready or college and career-ready
appear throughout the common core
standards the opening page of the Common
Core document in
News 8 references to college and
career-readiness if any other goal is
mentioned such as literacy it is
subservient to the overarching goal the
catchphrase for common core printed
below its logo is preparing American
students for college and career common
core's mission statement reflects this
notion as well here's the entire mission
statement of Common Core quote the
Common Core Standards provide a
consistent clear understanding of what
students are expected to learn so
teachers and parents know what they need
to do to help them the standards are
designed to be robust and relevant to
the real world reflecting the knowledge
and skills that young people need here
it is for success in college and careers
and the final line I want you to pay
special attention to with American
students fully prepared for the future
our communities will be positioned and
here it is to compete successfully in a
global economy
end quote with such a mission it's easy
to see why many politicians and the
business leaders support Common Core
even critics of Common Core have adopted
the college and career-ready mantra and
now spend much of their time arguing how
Common Core will not prepare students
for the working world I understand this
I understand that this line of attack is
necessary if we have or if they have any
hope of stopping Common Core but what I
would like for us to consider here today
is whether or not career pressure career
preparation for a global economy should
be the ultimate education goal in
America in the 1920s in our 30s
progressive educators tried to devalue
impractical liberal arts education and
saw schools as mechanisms for preparing
students for particular roles within the
social structure during this era
schooling became job preparation but in
the ancient world job preparation was
known as a servile education because it
prepared students to serve a master in a
particular kind of work a modern
education Act theorists would say that
I'm being ridiculous to associate
ancient notion of servile education with
skills for the 21st century which will
allow students to adapt to an
ever-changing society but as long as
students are told that the end of
Education is a job or a career they will
forever be servants of some master joy
Pullman an education policy analyst for
the Heartland Institute and a Hillsdale
grad by the way recently won the Robert
Novak award to study and write about
common core Pullman is quickly becoming
one of the nation's experts on common
core at a recent hearing in Wisconsin on
common core standards Pullman addressed
common core's misguided focus in a
self-governing nation
I'm sorry quote in a self-governing
nation we need citizens who can govern
themselves the ability to support
oneself with meaningful work is an
important part but only a part of
self-government we needn't I'm sorry
when a nation expands workforce training
so that it crowds out other things that
rightly belong in education we end up
turning out neither good workers nor
good citizens and quote the ancients
knew that in order for men to be truly
free they must have a liberal education
that includes study of literature and
history mathematics and science music
and art yes man is made for work but
he's also made for
much more education should be about the
highest things we should study these
things but the stars plant cells square
roots Shakespeare's Hamlet Mozart's
Requiem Lincoln's Gettysburg Address not
simply because they'll get us into the
right college or into the right line of
work rather we should study these noble
things because they can tell us who we
are why we're here what our relationship
is to each other as human beings into
the world that surrounds us among other
things
commenting on common core standards
Anthony Esalen English professor at
Providence College said this what
appalls me most about the standards is
the cavalier contempt for great works of
human art and thought and literary form
it is sheer ignorance of the life of the
imagination we are not programming
machines we are teaching children we are
we are to be forming the minds and
hearts of men and women and we should
raise them to be human beings honouring
what is good and right and cherishing
what is beautiful if education has
become as common core openly declares
preparation for work in a global economy
then this situation is far worse than
Common Core critics ever anticipated and
the concerns about cost and quality and
yes even the constitutionality of Common
Core pale in comparison to the concerns
of the hearts minds and souls of
Americans children thank you very much